alors et je suis allé sur doctissimo
parce que moi je suis comme un michel
blanchet hypocondriaque donc à chaque
fois que j'ai un petit truc je vais
taper sur doctissimo et quoi qu'il
arrive tu vois un bouton sur le coude et
se lie au bout de deux minutes ils te
disent attention parce que ça peut
s'enflammer et ça peut entraîner la mort
dont 48 servir à chaque fois et on
angoisse totale
donc je suis allé voir on a faim top 5
des questions que les gens se posent sur
le forum il y en a vraiment des
surprenantes
alors regardez première question bonjour
je me demandais si l'épilation du
maillot à la cire peut influencer sur la
virginité à force de tirer la cire je
suis vieille et je tends à leur
esthétique c'est vraiment une question
sur doctissimo
alors avec la réponse et attention on
arrêtait vous allez mourir et le truc
beau jour il ya deux jours je m'amusais
sur un arbre quand je suis tombé sur une
branche pointu emma testicules a faim
oui comme schlague les cas c'est foutu
ma vie de mettre de la colle mais bon
j'ai peur
[Applaudissements]
on donne déjà les yeux déjà c'est un
testicule
oui c'est vrai je tiens à préciser c'est
vrai que c'est une couille et un
testicule mésaventure est arrivée
personnes pauvres est avec un docteur
précédent fossiles il serait
testiculaire ça fait ch là j'ai fait je
l'aï pas sur un vélo alors lui connais
toutes les histoires de kujaa il était
derrière c'est que c'est toi et dr toi
tu avais un problème pas que tu joues
pas tu penses jamais ici enfin c'est à
n'en ont pas besoin médical
oui c'est vrai que c'est cool c'est pas
leur taux grimper son principal problème
là c'est sûr je suis contrainte à
l'abstinence depuis plusieurs mois et je
me pose une question est ce que mon
vagin pour échanger non je vous jure que
c'est vrai quoi ah oui oui et oui
personne c'est arrivé à bout d'un moment
où ce fait j'ai rarement pénétrer
l'oreille ça arrive mais faut vraiment
que sur le mont dans le noir total
oui que tu peux me permettre qu'il se
bouge pas mal hein
il se produit c'est l'impression que
c'était énorme
bougez pas mr sarr oui bien sûr moi j'ai
connu un bac +7 qui étaient perçus et
bic et j'étais pas ménopausée l'époque
précisant qu'il était persuadé comme ça
après la ménopause ne pouvait plus faire
l'amour parce que ça se remet ou chat
soit devant ou derrière c'est un muscle
alors ici
téléchargez tendres alors regardez sur
la prochaine question à gauche on a
parlé mais tout à fait vrai mais si on
perd la prochaine mais je crois que je
ne crois pas que ce soit une impression
mais matt est rétrécie j'ai encore tout
à fait normal mais ma tête et me est ce
que c'est parce que je me lave le visage
[Applaudissements]
c'était le top de sa possible mais c'est
quoi l'amour avec quelqu'un qui répond à
ces questions là bah oui je réponds
alors et ris le top 20 points nous voilà
bonjour je suis enceinte depuis six mois
je me pose énormément de questions
mon bébé peut-être tomber enceinte si je
veux la mort pendant qu il ya vraiment
une personne qui a prôné cette question
je vous le dis donc ça ça c'était je
voulais absolument vous le faire et ça
on a trouvé des perles ou dit leur
réponse
si la réponse est non
[Applaudissements]